Whenever the conversation of single fathers wants to come up,
I would really love if we would make note
that 41% of single fathers cohabitate with a partner.
So they're not really entirely doing it on their own.
They're working the same exact schedule.
They're working, and now they have just a different woman stepping in
doing exactly what they did.
Single mothers, only 16% of them cohabitate.
And I'm sure the living situation in the homes is very,
very different for single mothers who cohabitate
and single fathers who cohabitate.
Because a mom is still always gonna be a mom.
You're still always gonna have to do everything.
And the feminine duties, the wifely duties,
the womanly duties are almost always gonna fall on the woman.
So life doesn't really change that much for single fathers.
But for single mothers,
they have to figure out an entirely whole new way of living.
They have to figure out how to earn an income,
how to keep their kids safe,
how to do everything.
And even though 43% of men are cohabitating with women,
when they finally do get help and live with somebody else,
they're judged so hard. Are you keeping your kids safe?
Are you doing what's best for your kids?
You know, like,
slow down when we're starting the fucking applause.
When you see a single father,
like, calm the fuck down.